j'accueille maintenant serge lama
jamar bonsoir bonsoir ça va donc noémie
lenoir
oui oui c'est un petit peu c'est spécial
voila voila yvan attal qui a fait ma
femme est une actrice oui voilà serge
lama dont le dernier cd s'appelle
feuille à feuille
donc c'est un album entièrement consacré
aux cabanis et serge lama
comment ça va bien alors après de
longues années dans le symphonique vous
prenez le contre-pied de tout ce que
vous avez fait et vous faites de
l'acoustique du minimaliste là
subitement j'ai voulu faire quelque
chose de beaucoup plus dépouillée et on
est parti en tournée donc avec les
anciennes chansons dans un système
minimaliste mais surtout sans son piano
qui a changé beaucoup maviepro musiciens
son piano c'est sa dette publique
non non c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas il y avait beaucoup de public et pas
de piano jeff et l'océan indien
l'auxerrois oui j'ai fait le sud de
l'océan indien voilà la maman de noémie
de la reguera réunion voilà pour ça que
je dis ça oui l'île maurice
voilà l'île maurice et le québec
j'ai fait six semaines au québec où et
d'isabelle boulay il penaud j'aime ça je
les parfaites mais enfin j'ai fait que
deux succès attend donc non non j'ai
fait une chanson pour elle mais non ça
s'est arrêté là oui c'est pas comme
laurent gerra avec avec oui alors les
musiques ont fait promo là un sérieux
les musiques donc il ya yves gilbert
vous êtes avec lui depuis soixante
sépare vécu oui travailler par les voilà
depuis 66 alors ensuite parmi les
musiciens qui ont composé pour vous et
christophe leporatti nicolas manta zoo
qui a réalisé le disent d'ailleurs
sylvaris tu vois là sylvain michel
québécois qui québécois qui avec lequel
j'avais écrit une chanson justement pour
isabelle boulay et c'est pour ça que je
connais sylvain michel beaucoup plus que
il avait le boulet ouais encore que je
collais belle isabelle quand même mais
pas à ce point là non
la belle boulette
vous le direz vous êtes bien vu au
québec oui je pense mal vu au québec
parce que j'ai dit à une québécoise que
son accent se trouvait pas sa terrible
hein je reçois des lettres du québec
incroyable bah oui parce que c'est le
genre sale con en général mais sur un
bel accent et québécois simplement je
comprends qu au lycée doit pas être
évident ouais parfois je peux vous dire
c'est très agréable d'être avec une
québécoise isabelle boulay cinq minutes
se dire étoile des québécoises personnel
avec ou sans accent dakar alors on va
parler des paroles parce que vous avez
un problème ou qu'est le problème
inverse de julien clerc julien clerc en
parle toujours de ses paroliers on dit
toujours etienne roda-gil maurice vallet
jean nil à bali et c'est bon et on
oublie toujours que je viens car il a
fait quand même toutes les mélodies de
toutes ses chansons qu'elle le dit c'est
énorme je n'y ai filé rebonds et vous
c'est un peu pareil serre que on oublie
souvent que vous avez fait toutes les
paroles de toutes vos chansons quand
même c'est peut-être aussi parce que je
fais partie de ces chanteurs qui ont de
la voix et qui occulte beaucoup ce
qu'ils chantent une certaine manière on
écoute le chanteur et puis on en fait
c'est depuis mes débuts effectivement
j'ai connu mais tellement fort qu'on
comprend pas bien la balle a reproché un
peu mais c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ce
disque-là trois musiciens on comprend
tout voilà qui je chante un peu moins
fort aussi voilà j'ai fait un effort
pour vous savez comment on fait serge
lama oui avec les petites mains les
mimines noémie montrez lui adore ça
1 2 3
j'ai pas fait gaffe donc voila et le
single s'appelle quand est ce qu on fait
l'amour
ah c'est toi qui écrit les paroles donc
quand est ce qu'on fait
quand est on fait l'amour
on se parlait
d'ailleurs on se parlait d'un dieu
on se disait un jour
m
on se regarde et aubin
on s'appuyer au tas
on s'agrippe et hopper qui étranglait
nos coeurs qui nous fait donc
centro chine ont toutes les paroles
maintenant oui alors c'est pas c'est pas
la plus littéraire du disque il ya
d'autres qui ne se jouera sur ma fille y
en a d'autres qui sont un peu plus
littéraire mais sais tu sais je sais
voilà alors inspiration toujours les
femmes
oui enfin l'amour le couple les rapports
la nostalgie la nostalgie aussi comme
mais comme tout le monde j'ai 18 ans
vous aviez écrit une chanson qui
s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans donc
c'est vraiment le roi de la nostalgie
parce qu'à 18 ans à une chanson qui
s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans oui ceci
dit les beatles yesterday
il ne fait pas tellement vieux non plus
c'est vrai je crois qu'on est
nostalgique très tôt ouais ouais
à 15 ans après je m'en sors mais on va
parler de vos 15 ans justement
alors serge lama vous êtes né en 1943
oui vous êtes le fils unique de georges
et georgette chauvier et on va parler de
votre père parce que le destin de votre
père vous a marqué et finalement à
décider du vôtre d'une certaine façon
totalement mais c'est vrai alors votre
grand-père lui déjà le père de votre
père n'était pas quelqu'un de très
gentil hein
non non non c'était quelqu'un qui était
très violent qui qui qui buvaient et qui
taper mon père avec la avec sa ceinture
place aux et malheureusement ça s'est
encore et ça se faisait beaucoup à
l'époque et et mon père a été mis aux
enfants assistés il a eu une enfance
assez assez douloureuse mais c'est
difficile
alors votre père quitte aubusson avec sa
mère à l'âge de 5 ans ils vont à
bordeaux
et quand il a 15 ans il s'inscrit dans
une société qui s'appelle la girondine
et il rentre au conservatoire de
bordeaux il a grand prix et il peut pas
chanter sur scène pourquoi c'était une
douleur pour lui il pense que
normalement c'est comme au conservatoire
de paris quand on est comédien ont
généralement on mange on jouait la
comédie française et puis normalement au
théâtre de bordeaux aujourd'hui jouer au
grand théâtre et puis pour des raisons
de politique interne il n'a jamais pu le
faire et ça a été une de ses premières
blessures une de ses premières blessures
justement parce qu'on va voir y aidera
beaucoup donc il fait pas de scène il
n'a pas d'imprésario alors un moment il
dit je vais changer de nom parce que
c'est vrai que chauvier bon pas terrible
comme non la preuve c'est que vous aussi
vous en avez changé la cause du prénom
il s'appelait georges jor-el chauvier
jean chauvet serge chevalier c'est
pareil à rennes comme c'est pas possible
il faudra arriver site de simplement
georges gavarnie clavier même il avait
essayé et six claviers clavier georges
clavier puis ça c'était pas terrible non
plus gavarnie gavarnie ça ressemblait un
peu à guéthary donc il s'est dit et ça
va marcher
j étais beau votre personnel à maui le
très beau et selon les critères de
l'époque oui c'est un besoin physique à
la robert taylor
on appelait le prince charmant de la
chanson il décide de monter à paris vous
montez pas tout de suite vous restez un
an à bordeaux avec votre grand mère
et quand vous venez à paris c'est pas
drôle du tout vous retrouver tous dans
une petite chambre dans un meublé
votre père votre mère votre grand mère
vous dans le 7e arrondissement rue du
vivier et votre père beils fini au bout
d'un moment par décrocher un engagement
au delà des capucines
il a joué aux capucines dans une revue
c'est là que j'ai connu mes premières
danseuses nues et c'est là effectivement
que j'ai connu aussi nadine palier qui
fusaient et une amie à nous était assise
là ya pas longtemps madame de rothschild
oil souvient la grande copine méridienne
rôle nadine dan a dit elle jouait sur
scène nue avec le père de serge lama est
l'un des premiers à voir les seins de
nadine talent y est voilà c'est la
presse la joue un peu comme ça mais
c'est une [ __ ] c'est une
merveilleuse fille elle a doublé bardot
dans certains sites non la poêle
il ya des films de bardot s'est fixé
nadine qui tique qui pose pour la
poitrine et alors c'est à cette époque
que va naître votre vocation plus vous
voyez votre père qui êtes aux capucines
et enfin c'est à l'olympia et un jour
vous avez 12 ans évite à votre père moi
un jour papa je serai en face oui parce
que tous les nouveaux tous les plus
grands ce commencé à passer à l'olympia
c'est les débuts de béco dont on
n'imagine pas aujourd'hui la carrière un
cas urgent hilbert c'était énorme énorme
à la casse et les premiers fauteuils
pour lui c'était d'ailleurs il n'était
même pas en vedette il était en
américaine de lucienne delille
je me souviens de sa eddie constantine à
une star immense et je voyais ces noms
briller sur ce fronton et et je rêvais
alors vous voulez donc allé à l'olympia
et c'est l'époque où vous écrivez vos
premières chansons vous êtes fasciné
parce que votre père écrivait aussi il a
été chanté par mariano bah oui c'est là
que le drame arrive votre mère en fait
c'était une minette au départ qui
étaient autant qu'il existe un beau
chanteur et elle est venue eu de cesse
que de le faire arrêter comme ça arrive
assez souvent
alors que
elle était très jalouse et puis c'était
terrible ce qu'on vivait lancé quand
même dans une touchante elle me plait
tous les soirs j'entendais les
engueulades mois dans le livre un scellé
les scènes mais les scènes horribles
qu'a lui faisait pas ce qu'il aurait pu
chanter mon père il refusait détourné à
cause de sa jalousie des tournées de six
mois parce qu elle prétexté que c'était
pas métier certain mais sûr que pour
manger tous les jours c'était pas comme
mes gamins pas que ça il aurait pu vivre
de son métier mais en fait elle voulait
pas quoi ce qui est évident c'est
histoire c'est qu'elle a épousé parce
que c'était un chanteur et une fois
qu'elle a été avec lui et il lui est
interdit d'être chanteur quoi c'est bah
oui c'est ça voulait le garder à l
esprit castratrice avec moi aussi à
l'essai par l'assemblée mais c'est en
même temps une femme elle même mais je
veux dire elle aimait mon père mais ces
deux là c'est de l'amour qui tue l'amour
et je leur ai pas retrouvé cette époque
là pour dire la vérité parce que j'ai
été très malheureux pendant dix ans je
reprendrai tout voyez toute ma vie même
l'accident
mais cette période là je les reprendrai
mon pied alors à force de le tarauder le
pauvre il a décidé d'arrêter l'hiver 54
l'hiver terrible hiver de l'abbé pierre
ou j'ai tellement froid il vous annonce
à tout ce qu'il a décidé d'accepter
l'offre d'un ancien patron du théâtre
des capucines qui s'appelait paul board
qui a été reconvertie dans la limonade
et donc y voit là il devient
représentant bière sur ce type d'un seul
coup dit non à sa carrière et le dernier
soir c'était la bc il est la doublure de
guéthary était la fin de sa carrière
était doublure de guetteur et le
lendemain matin et partez sur son solex
et sans maquillage
il voyait toujours très bien à ranger
votre père
en tout ils étaient beaux sous les
lumières il avait beau fixe à canadienne
le soir et puis malheureux quoi bien sûr
malheureux il pleurer parfois oui il se
confier à vous et vous vous le disiez
écoute papa part il faut que tu partes
il faut que tu te casses d'ici et ils
vous répondez non je peux pas y à toi
oui et moi je lui dis c'est pas une
raison parce qu'on est beaucoup plus
malheureux quand on est enfant et que
les parents ne s'entendent pas moi
j'entendais des engueulades permanente
n'était pas mieux j'aurais bonjour et
par ta fille j'aurais tellement été
heureux que mon père continue et serait
même changé sûrement ma propre vie et
j'étais assez précoce pour entendre ça
et je me suis battu mais il restait
quand même et ça fait son malheur et une
partie du mien dans cette période j'ai
écrit là-dessus des chansons un peu un
peu il ya le temps de la rengaine où je
raconte cette histoire qui est une des
rares chansons autobiographiques enfin
réellement autobiographique
tiens un autre autobiographique je
pouvais voir la petite femme de pillage
des croisés
et voilà voilà l'histoire de serge lama
quand votre père prends la décision
d'arrêter vous prenez la décision d'y
arriver
peut-être grâce à je suis à regarder la
sentais bien l'assureur fait à quel prix
peut-être pas il ya des prix à payer qui
sont peut-être pas trace reda voilà donc
après vous allez vivre toute la famille
dans un petit appartement issy les
moulineaux ça va mieux évidemment il a
une vie plus régulière va ça va mieux
cg puis c'est l'arrivée des années les
premiers crédits on peut acheter la
petite voiture et on partait le dimanche
comme tout le monde l'a sur les routes
allez manger le poulet dans dans l'herbe
avec les fourmis mais je détestais les
pique niqueurs elle avec les tables en
scène musicale et j'ai été contraint de
suivre
alors voilà et quand votre père c'est
sahélienne l'épilogué cette histoire
quand votre père à 60 ans il prend sa
pré retraite
vous faites un album avec lui qui
s'appelle la main père et fils et pour
vos vingt ans de carrière vous lui
offrez la scène du rex
oui c'est beau très très très bon
souvenir une tournée aussi une fait une
tournée d'une quarantaine de dates et
c'était un moment merveilleux on dirait
qu'on prévoit les choses sont le cadet a
c'est vrai parce que mon père est mort
dans un accident de voiture
neuf mois après oui en soit 184 pendant
napoléon avec ma mère aussi puisqu'ils
ont eu le même accident et ils sont
morts tous les deux et peut-être sans le
savoir je lui ai offert sa dernière
dernière grande joie oui c'est bien oui
et c'est je ne regrette pas cet
amendement mais piste ya le règlement
c'est un moment j'ai un souvenir de ce
rex c'était on a fait trois jours
c'était merveilleux c'est peut-être le
plus gros souvenir que j'ai de music
hall à paris ouais du fantastique dans
serge slama vous êtes un petit peu
marqué par les accidents il faut bien
dire quand même que tout court
maintenant la norme et non mais c'est
vrai au début de votre carrière
l'accident très grave enrico macias nous
en a parlé d'ailleurs avec son frère
décédé dans la voiture jean claude
massias
et puis il y avait aussi dit yann
benedick était votre grand amour wick a
marqué tout
c'était la pianiste delescluse la
pianiste de l'éclusé qui accompagne tous
les gens qui parce qu'amazon mois de
tous les plus grands des gens sont
passés là bas c'était une femme
merveilleuse et puis cette annonce et
âme était en plein ciel poids au moment
où c'était le pain vous restez vous
restez un an et demi couchez vous
réapprenez un marché très difficilement
c'est vrai qu'à 24 ans et c'est
difficile de se remettre d'un marché où
on me donnait aucune chance je pense que
c'est mon métier qui m'a sauvé peu à peu
la vie reprend ses droits à l'hosto vous
rencontrez daisy voilà donc comme quoi
finalement un déclic chez philippe voilà
et qu'est-ce que je me suis raccroché
raccrocher à elle pour survivre lorsque
peut-être peut-il être pas rencontré
daisy je commençais à avoir du mal à
tenir moralement ouais et alors c'est
marrant enfin marrant c'est étonnant
c'est sur un brancard que vous
enregistrez votre premier succès les
ballons rouges